hey everyone what's up i
wanted to record this short little video
because i've been thinking a bit about
some other ways in which i might be able
to reach students with my courses and my
teaching in r
and so in particular
there's
so my my course the way that it works
now it's a self-paced online
pre-recorded course when you sign up you
get the course forever you can follow it
whenever you want at your own pace
that's the whole point but for some
people that just doesn't really work so
well
it
for some people they need a little bit
more structure or like a deadline a goal
more of the sort of traditional format
where you have a
course and and you meet certain number
of times uh you have regal weekly
regular weekly wrigley meetings you have
regular weekly meetings
and a particular time when you know the
course is going to be done and for some
people they prefer that type of
structure
so long story short i wanted to
think about opening up a few other ways
in which i can offer my course and my
teachings
and so one idea is to offer a one-on-one
coaching
system where we meet a certain number of
times maybe work through the course
material together and together we can
set goals for when you want to complete
the course and by meeting regularly with
me we can make sure that you're meeting
those goals answer any questions along
the way
and really help you
learn r in sort of that more structured
format so another method another idea
might be to have sort of do the same
thing but
with a group so a group of people maybe
go through the lessons
in a live sort of manner
meeting
within a regular within a regular
schedule
and and working through the course
material that way that's another option
so but i'm also open to any ideas that
you might have and and that's why i
wanted to make this video out there so
if you have any suggestions for ways in
which
the
the course material could be structured
or presented whether it's me one on one
or maybe you sign up for the course and
you get the material regularly sort of
dripped to you every week
i just want to get more feedback on
especially from people that might be
interested in doing some kind of a
one-on-one or group coaching
my end goal again is to
help you learn r so if you're not sure
if you've been frustrated and you feel
like ours is kind of overwhelming demon
that you have to get over in order to
get through your dissertation to get
through grad school or even just to to
be a good scientist in general
it but it but if it creates kind of that
impediment kind of invokes that feeling
of anxiety in you
my goal is to help you get rid of that
and whether it's through the self-paced
course that i have or whether you would
like to work together one-on-one or as
part of a group whatever method works
best for you i want to know about it so
that i can try to
make those offerings available and make
those those systems available so that
no matter where you're at what learning
style you have i can i can help you out
so with that i've been rambling a bit
but i hope the message
is clear and
let's see let me make sure i didn't miss
anything
ah very important if any of these things
sound interesting to you in particular
group coaching or one-on-one coaching or
any other kind of new methodology for
for how i can teach you r
there is a little landing page that i
made a little place where you can put
your email to
sign up and and learn more when when i
make these offerings available
uh so
yeah just um the link should be down
below in the description i don't know
where this video will be but the link
should be it should be clear
so with that i'm gonna sign out and hope
you have a great rest of your day
alright take care